hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel it
has been a hot minute since i've made
any sort of like desk related video so
today i want to talk about my favorite
desk accessories by the way i'm also
going to be filming like an office tour
video as well as like some other gadget
review thing so if you're interested in
that kind of content then make sure to
subscribe so yeah i've made a bunch of
updates and not only that but i've also
kind of lived with these updates for a
few months at least and so i can
actually really talk about all these
things in depth about what i like about
them and sometimes what i don't like
about them i'm going to introduce a
bunch of these dust accessory things to
you today so let's get started by the
way i just want to call out thank you to
logitech for sponsoring today's video
i'm really excited to talk about their
products which are part of my new
favorite desk accessory so stay tuned
the first item that i want to talk about
are my felt right tiles these are the
tiles that you see right behind me
they're set up right on the wall behind
my monitor i really wanted to have
something that was more visually
pleasing to look at than just a white
wall i also didn't want something as
distracting as like artwork and wanted
something just a little bit more like to
add some textural and color variety to
my workspace so i thought about getting
sound tiles for a very long time because
then it also helps kind of stamp in my
room a little bit sound wise and then i
think i got like an instagram ad or
something for felt right and felt right
is this company that makes all these
sound dampening like things that are all
made of wool and so they have a bunch of
different styles and colors and shapes i
went for the hexagon ones but i know
they also have like subway tile
rectangular looking things as well a
bunch of different designs they were
super duper easy to install they just
use like double-sided tape i used
actually the cracking the coding
interview book as a spacer between all
of my tiles because i wanted them to be
uniform and i didn't know what else to
use in terms of the sound dampening
quality i wouldn't say that it's like
massive i mean this is just one
part of one wall of the four walls in my
room and so i wouldn't say that i've
noticed a huge drastic difference in the
sound itself it hasn't gotten worse like
the sound in my room hasn't gotten worse
it maybe has gotten better i have no way
to actually measure that like
objectively speaking but i do know that
these sometimes really do get used in
actual sound dampening applications and
what's cool about these is you can also
like pin things to them which i might do
at some point but i still just wanted to
keep it really nice and basic and the
colors are really pretty it matches all
the greenery in my room and so really
happy with how it turned out honestly
the next item that i want to talk about
is my elgato key light so i've been
wanting some sort of key light on my
desk for a while and i chose the elgato
one just because i knew that it was like
a really popular product and it has been
such an upgrade for my desk specifically
the thing that it's really helped with
is that it provides some good lighting
to my face when i'm in like video calls
or doing interviews and stuff like that
i don't have any good lighting from that
wall onto my face and so especially if
it's in the evening or something like
that it illuminates my face and kind of
like creates a nice soft glow i guess
you can connect this key light
wirelessly to your computer for controls
where you can adjust brightness and
warmth another thing that i really like
about this one is that it's got a really
minimal design and so i like that it's
kind of got this like rectangular shape
with rounded edges the build quality is
honestly really good and i got the
version that latches onto my desk the
head itself is like fully adjustable it
can swivel in every direction 360
whatever that is and so sometimes i'll
honestly just use it as a desk light but
yeah really great upgrade for me
especially because now is the age of
like zoom meetings and online meetings
sometimes at like five o'clock or six
o'clock or seven o'clock or just like
the sun goes down early and whatever so
really really great upgrade for my desk
the next item that i want to talk about
is my new keyboard which is the logitech
mx mechanical mini so i was on this
keyboard from logitech it's the brand
new mechanical keyboard from logitech i
was so so so excited to use this one
because y'all know i'm just a huge fan
of like logitech products in general so
i've used like every version of the mx
keys since like four years ago and i
really really like it and this keyboard
has honestly a lot of the same things
that i liked about the mx key and really
like any other logitech keyboard in
general because they're all really well
made so things like being able to
connect wirelessly through bluetooth or
the logibolt usb receiver the fact that
it can connect up to three devices it
charges with usbc no battery is required
and the keys are programmable and can
have app specific settings that last
part is actually like game changer like
literally being able to program my keys
to different apps specifically things
like premiere pro and coding ides has
made my workflow just so much smoother
and so the difference with this keyboard
is that the keys are mechanical and
honestly it's got that really nice
mechanical keyboard quality of like
tactileness and the sound but it's not
too loud
i chose the tactile quiet browns for
this one because i i know i like tactile
quiet keys but it also comes in a linear
red and a clicky blue the logitech mx
mechanical keyboard comes in two
different size factors one with a numpad
and the other without which is the one
that i have the thing to note about
these keys which i think like kind of
differentiates it from other mechanical
keyboards is that the keys are really
slim profile so it's almost as if you
could get like a like a slim profile
keyboard but the keys are mechanical
which i feel like in a lot of ways are
like the best of two worlds so yeah this
mechanical keyboard honestly so good
it's i think it's actually more like
full specced than most other mechanical
keyboards out there because of all the
features that logitech already brings to
all of their keyboards so if you're
looking for a mechanical keyboard you're
just looking to get into it then this is
a great keyboard the next time that i
want to talk about is again another
logitech product which is the mx master
3s so a logitech keyboard begs for a
logitech mouse because it's really the
combination of these two that really
unlock the true power of this ecosystem
i was using the mx master 3 for mac
prior to this and this does actually
really feel like a huge upgrade from the
previous one and specifically the thing
that i like the most like literally when
i used it for the first time i was i was
like so delighted i was like whoa okay
and that's the quiet click functionality
basically when you click using the right
or left button it's literally just so
quiet again this has all the features
that i've loved about the logitech mx
master series from all the previous
versions and improved upon it so things
like how you can charge it using a usb
connection honestly it doesn't need to
charge very often i maybe charge it like
once every two months i want to say and
the charging port is in the front of the
mouse so you can use it while you're
charging very underrated feature i gotta
say this one you can also connect
wirelessly to up to three devices using
bluetooth or the logi bolt receiver and
the thing that i was talking about about
like what makes it so powerful in
conjunction with the keyboard is that
it's also programmable and so you can
have basic settings as well as app
specific settings that really help your
workflow like truly i've gotten so much
faster at editing things to these two
products like it is a game changer the
other thing that i really really like
about this mouse is the color i had like
all the previous versions which were
like gray which is great but this one
comes in a beautiful uh like grayish
whitish color and i feel like it matches
the rest of my desk better and the
updates don't stop just at the color so
there's also a customizable pointer
speed now it tracks well on glass the
mouse itself is made from recycled
plastic it comes in responsible
packaging and it's a carbon neutral
product so yeah honestly this is another
just so such a good mouse so if you're
gonna buy one mouse buy this one the
next time i should come at no surprise
for my subscribers because it's my grove
made desk mat this is a long time
favorite i feel like i've talked about
it in almost every other desk setup
video this is a desk map that i put my
keyboard and mouse on made by grovemade
it's made of wool and i've used it for i
want to say like almost two years and
it's held up super well the wool
honestly has gotten softer over time and
so it's really actually kind of
comfortable to like put my hands on
think of it as like my home base that
creates like a house for like my
keyboard and mouse and it's nice that
it's just like it's comfy to like use as
well it doesn't pill at all it's just a
really high quality good product and the
other thing is that it just looks really
good on my desk too
just beautiful the next thing that i
want to talk about which i guess you'd
call it a desk accessory i'm going to
call it a dust accessory is my desktop
wallpaper so i kind of feel like
wallpaper choice is like underrated i
feel like having a good wallpaper on
your desktop especially when you have
such a huge screen like mine really kind
of helps set the tone and mood for
whatever you're doing at your desk the
wallpaper that i have is from kuroku and
it's from the taiyo series it was
actually made by my friend tom who runs
the channel bite review i saw this
wallpaper i think on his desk and i was
like dude where did you get that
wallpaper and then i found out that it
made it it comes in a variety of
different colors it's got really some
nice like organic shapes that kind of
remind you of nature but like not so
much that there's so much detail on it i
just think it looks really really nice
with the rest of my desk set up i
believe he also has a lot of other
wallpapers and stuff too and so
definitely check his stuff out and the
last desk accessory that i want to talk
about is my wireless charger so a lot of
our personal devices have some sort of
wireless charging functionality to it so
you know things like my iphone and my
airpods need charging all the time and
so i really like having this wireless
charger that i found on amazon on my
desk i really actually like the design
of it which is one of the main reasons
why i chose it the cross tells you
exactly where to put your device to make
sure that it charges and it has a small
indicator light to tell you if it's
charging or not plugs in the back with a
usbc connection and i just think it
blends really well with everything else
that's going on on my desk my primary
use for this is to charge my airpods
because as soon as i get out of like a
zoom meeting or something like that and
i take my air pods out i put it on the
case and then i just set it on the
wireless charger to make sure that it's
charged for my next session so i'm like
never out of airpod battery i've had
this for like i want to say at least a
year and i have had zero problems with
it and so
honestly a great product alright so
those are all of my favorite desk
accessories let me know what you thought
in the comments down below and if
there's any parts of my desk setup
itself that you want me to cover in an
independent video i'll leave links for
everything in the description box down
below and i also want to thank logitech
again for sending me those products and
sponsoring this video don't forget to
subscribe to my channel and i will see
you next time bye
[Music]